So, Intel Inside® was a great example of joint business development.
They managed to exchange advertising dollars
for a prominent position on the outside of computer manufacturer's boxes.
What computer manufacturers got in exchange
was gross margin that they never would have gotten in a low-margin business.
Starbucks® and Pepsi™ to promote Frappuccino®
was a great example of a strategic alliance.
Apple and the record labels was another example
of a great strategic alliance, but Apple and Foxconn is a great example
of a supplier and might, at times, actually be a good example
of a joint venture as well.
Fashion week, well that's an example of coopetition.
Normally, at other times of the year, these high-end clothing manufacturers
compete with each other vociferously,
but once a year they get together and cooperate in grading the industry.
Standards groups are another example where competitors get together,
put aside their differences, and work together towards a common goal
of trying to come up with a set of mutually agreed standards.
Kind of the ringer in here, that is the one that I didn't describe,
but all you had to do was go on Google,
is the most famous aircraft partnership ever made
where 2 of the most unlikely partners, GE and a French aircraft manufacturer,
came together to do a joint venture for the CFM-56 jet engine,
which is one of the most popular turbofans in the world,
so that was a great example of a joint venture
and also had a bit of coopetition in it as well.
Finally, for traffic partners.
If you think about all the online scheduling sites, KAYAK, Expedia, Hipmunk,
they're all traffic partners for the airline industry.
In fact, that's how they make their money.
While you're having a great time figuring out multiple airline schedules,
every time you click through to by a ticket,
they are getting paid by the airlines, and that's how they make their money.
So, I hope these were good examples to help you understand
the different types of relationships.
As I said, sometimes they kind of blur between each other.
Sometimes it might start with coopetition and turn into a strategic alliance
and someday might actually be a joint venture,
but the whole idea is that you're working together with others
to help build your company.